you collaborated on your previous film
talk about how you are working together
and how you immediately went from a dark
film about a sad relationship to
something a great love my films are all
come from a very personal place I work
with what I know and what I've
experienced and I in my 40s I've
discovered love in a way that I wasn't
certain was possible and and that's
partially because I've met a wonderful
person and I've married my husband and
we actually now raising two kids and and
Boris actually did the paintings that
you see in the film for John so it's a
family affair but it's not the fact that
i got married it's it's it's actually
what came in my 40s was it was a sense
of comfort with myself which I think was
necessary to be ready to love in a new
kind of way and so the film really
contains that optimism that I feel about
love I'm also in the middle very much of
what I hope is the middle of my life and
the film is very deeply about
perspectives you've got John and Alfred
who are in the later passages and
chapters and you have marissa's
characters later who's Marissa has very
much in the middle of and asking the
questions of what is allowed and what is
expected and then you have this kid
played by this extraordinary young actor
Charlie to Han who was discovering
things for the first time and so what we
wanted to do was make a
multi-generational family epic but
within the confines of a small New York
apartment which was somebody's real
small New York apartment was it not the
the apartment that they gave up yes the
the the apartment that you see the
opening of film is actually we ran into
looking on locations it's it's actually
in Jackson Heights and it's a couple two
men who had been together for 47 years i
believe we called them the real ben and
george and and they let us into our home
we our collaboration is a lot of four
starts with a lot of lots of
conversations we talk a lot first you
know we have the
idea of what we want to talk about and
in this case it was we knew from the
start that we want to talk about this
older couple who have been together for
a long time and who have spent most of
their lives together from that point on
we just have lots of course asia's we
watch lots of movies and we end up
picking up scenes and interesting what
you know we interesting scenes and we
develop the characters and the scenes
together and then later on I go on my
own and I right up I give a give
structure and form to the ideas and I
come up with a first draft and then
there's a lot of back and forth you know
ice in the first half and in this case
was it was I was very surprised that you
know the the first draft was really well
received by I very mediately because
usually notes it's it's rougher but i
think we had the story in our minds if
so well I mean we developed the
characters and the arcs it was easy it
was an easy turning this without an
image in your mind of John or Fred
without the actors specifically without
the actors specifically yes yeah I mean
we draw a lot on real people that the
film is ultimately handed over to these
wonderful people but I think in the
process we were thinking of people we
know including I think for both of us
our parents you know my mother's been
with my stepfather for 43 years and my
birds have been together for more than
50 years and there was a you know a big
inspiration was there rehearsal exercise
trust Falls anything that you did in
order to fall in love with each other so
no you know I had known Fred for 20
years and I'd never worked with him I
wouldn't say we were close friends but
we were very very good friends mainly
through mutual friends in particular we
had a dear friend a character actress
Eileen gets who I in her forties passed
away of cancer had a terrible death and
Fred and I and several
other of her good New York actor friends
would hang out in her hospital ward and
that was when I first really got to know
Fred and discovered what I just a real
men she was what a big heart and what a
compassionate and funny man he is I I
the script was sent to me by buy it by
my agent had been quite closely watching
and I think helping with the project
there had been another actor whose name
I will not tell you until he was set to
play adhesive world-class one of my
idols and for some reason he chose not
to play it it would have been an
extremely different and a very
interesting film with him your
tantalizing us now I i well I won't do
it actually it was in the press when he
dropped out and I sneaked in but I it
was the best thing that ever happened to
me I I read the script and absolutely
loved it it was a beautiful piece of
writing it was like it was like writing
a perfect short Alice Munro short story
or something and met I were the next
morning and spent an hour with him just
talking and I was completely sold
interestingly I had a choice to make
between playing a small role in a great
big film interstellar and a big role in
this very small film and I was all set
to choose this one and then that same
agent somehow managed to get me a time
to do both things so I was negotiable
he's mine you can't have him he's mine I
was doing a movie with the same
producers of this that parts and labor
Lars and Jay and we were working on a
movie that I was co-producing with them
actually and that my friends had written
and they were about to go into this
movie and someone dropped out yeah
and so we were all in the set together
and so I I said I'm a great admirer of
IRAs and my eyes lit up at the
possibility that this could that there
might be an opening there and so that's
how I got involved I knew I wanted to do
it without even having read the script
you're the one woman among men and boys
I mean it's a household full of there's
the Sun there's the strange Vlad what's
going on with those two curiously in the
script the song was the famous Mickey
and Sylvia love is strange which is
where the title came from but by sort of
legal quirk parts and labors was allowed
to have either the song in the movie or
the title of the movie and they chose
the title and went out and found baby
you got what it takes which is a much
better song a wonderfully upbeat and
rahu Brooks that's exactly I could never
remember his name Brook Benton and
interestingly that is the very first
thing I shot on the film and the first
time Fred and I acted together on the
film we got together for an hour on a
Saturday with a pianist jazz vocalist
who coached us and then 48 hours later
there we were in front of all those
extras belting it out like we'd been
belting it out for 40 years we I
consider that my my greatest achievement
on the film was making making it look
like these guys at a long history when
they had a history of about two minutes